The mind-blowing second season of The Umbrella
Academy is loaded with hidden details, comic
book easter eggs, and a trail of clues predicting
the big cliffhanger ending.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing everything you missed
in The Umbrella Academy Season 2.
Just before we begin, I want to thank the
sponsor of this video, Squarespace.
More on why they're a great place to build
a website at the end.
Spoilers ahead so take care if you're not
caught up.
One of the many great things about Season
2 was seeing Pogo again, this time as a baby,
and discovering that he was once a budding
astronaut.
And there was a little easter egg to the chimpanzee's
time in space in the scene where Five tries
to buy some candy from a vending machine.
To the left of the candy that Five wants is
another chocolate bar called Pogo Gogos, with
the slogan "Take flight with Pogo Gogos",
suggesting perhaps that after going into space
the astrochimp became something of a celebrity,
at least enough to get a chocolate bar name
after him.
And take an even closer look at the candy
bar because there's a secret sparrow symbol
hidden inside one of the letters,
a sneaky easter egg to the rival team that
the Umbrella gang discover has taken their
place at the academy when they return to 2019.
In fact, this secret sparrow is just one of
many clues planted throughout Season 2 that
hint to the new Sparrow Academy.
In the third episode, there's a sparrow on
the bath towel at the hotel where the Handler
is staying,
and when Lila is thinking about what to eat,
you can spot a little sparrow on the hotel
menu.
Also a flock of birds, possibly sparrows,
form the Umbrella symbol for the opening titles
of that episode.
In addition to that, there's a sparrow on
a calendar at Allison and Ray's house.
And there are a couple of sparrow-like birds
in a picture frame on the wall of the meeting
room where Five goes to kill the Commission's
board of directors.
You can also see a sparrow symbol on the blackboard
inside Reginald Hargreeves' secret room.
And when Old Man Five opens his briefcase
just before the Kennedy assassination, you
can see a sparrow emblem on a paper just above
Vanya's book from Season 1.
And then there's a small sparrow on the Kill
Order that the Handler issued for Lila's parents.
In the finale, you can also spot the new Sparrow
Academy coat of arms on Ben's jacket and also
on the wall behind Hargreeves.
Some other interesting connections that certain
characters may have with the Sparrow Academy
are the Handler who wears a bath towel on
her head with a little bird on top,
and Sissy's son Harlan often plays with a
toy bird throughout Season 2 which we also
see him levitating in the finale.
This is just a theory, but could Harlan grow
up to become the father of one of the Sparrow
Academy team?
And is the Handler or the Commission involved
at all in the formation of the Sparrows?
Given the sheer number of sparrow clues throughout
Season 2,
it's almost as if the creation of the Sparrow
Academy was inevitable the moment the Umbrella
Academy jumped back in time to the 60s and
began changing the timeline.
In Season 2, Luther struggles with his situation
especially after he falls out with Jack Ruby
and discovers that his crush Allison is happily
married with another man.
So, he resorts to comfort eating as a way
of dealing with his unhappiness.
The scenes of Luther cooking an enormous mound
of eggs or munching his way through plates
of BBQ
are a hat tip to the second volume of the
comic books in which Luther falls into a depression
and ends up becoming morbidly obese.
Tom Hopper, who plays Luther, told Nerdist
that the TV series decided against using a
"full-on fat suit" for his character as Marvel
did that recently in Avengers: Endgame with
Thor.
When Luther heads out for a run, the show
tips its hat to the training scenes in the
Rocky movies where Sylvester Stallone runs
through the streets in a grey tracksuit and
kids run along with him.
Luther's running scene ends rather less victoriously
than Rocky's though as he trips and ends up
face-down on the ground after he mistakenly
thinks he's seen Allison.
The Umbrella Academy's powers really level
up in Season 2 with Klaus mastering how to
manifest spirits in the real world.
However, comic book Klaus also has the power
of levitation and Season 2 makes a funny reference
to this when we see him floating miraculously
in mid-air in front of his cult,
the joke, of course, being that he's actually
being lifted up by the invisible Ben.
We get an awesome Five vs Five fight scene
in episode nine when schoolboy Five and Old
Man Five are gripped by a homicidal urge to
kill each other due to the effects of Paradox
Psychosis.
The pair try to outmanoeuvre each other using
spatial jumps in a very cool scene appropriately
set to the tune of Dancing With Myself.
The scene is a nod to Avengers: Endgame where
Captain America travelled back in time and
ended up fighting with his past self.
And there's another homage to Captain America
when, during the fight, schoolboy Five drops
Steve Roger's iconic line:
"I can do this all day."
"Yeah, I know.
I know."
And, of course, both scenes are a wink to
fans of the 1960s animated Spider-Man cartoon
where the real Spidey faces off with a Spider-Man
imposter,
a moment that became a hugely popular meme
and was recently given a fresh twist in Spider-Man
into the Spider-Verse.
In Season 2, Diego's hero complex really takes
over as he becomes obsessed with trying to
save President Kennedy.
But there was a little detail in the season's
opening scene you might have missed that sets
Diego apart from his siblings.
Whereas everyone else crashed to the ground
when they dropped out of the sky in the 60s,
Diego instead managed a stylish superhero
landing, very much in character with his hero
complex.
"Superhero landing!
You know, that's really hard on your knees."
The Handler made a surprise return in Season
2 proving herself an outrageously ruthless
villain.
And one of the biggest WTF moments came when
she decided to end A.J.'s attempts to interfere
with her plans once and for all, by grabbing
the goldfish and swallowing him whole.
This is actually a shout-out to the comics
where Five took his revenge on the goldfish
head of the Commission, Carmichael, by eating
him alive.
However, in a brief flashback scene where
the Handler stamps the kill order for Lila's
parents, if you look very closely, just above
the stamp you can see A.J.'s full name: Atlas
Jericho Carmichael.
Also on the desk next to the kill order, you
can just make out the corner of a receipt
from Griddy's Doughnuts.
Griddy's is the donut shop from the first
season where Hazel met and fell in love with
Agnes.
In Season 2, human Grace discovers a hidden
room filled with Reginald Hargreeves' research.
And on the blackboard are plans for something
called "The Televator", which is described
as "the next great mode of transportation".
In the comics, the Televator is a machine
invented by Hargreeves and Klaus has one built
to transport him, Luther and Pogo from Vietnam
to Dallas.
The Televator easter egg in the TV show might
be a hint that we'll see this device in a
future season, especially given it also made
an appearance on a comic-book cover in Season
1.
And there's an easter egg to another Hargreeves
invention from the comics, this time the breakfast
cereal Clever Crisp, which appears on the
kitchen table in Elliot's home.
Another comic book easter egg crops up when
Five complains that his siblings failed to
show up for their time jump back to 2019:
"All we had to do was be here.
Didn't have to fight a giant sea monster,
no."
This is a nod to the comic book short story
"But the Past Ain't Through With You" where
the Umbrella Academy were delayed on a mission
after having to battle a sea serpent in the
Pacific Ocean.
Just before the Umbrella gang return from
1963 to 2019, we see a brief scene of Jack
Ruby watching a news report about the Kennedy
assassination.
Then there's a very quick shot of him grabbing
a gun, a subtle reference to how in real life
Ruby fatally shot Lee Harvey Oswald while
he was in Dallas police custody.
Oswald was the primary suspect in the Kennedy
murder investigation at the time, and Ruby
claimed he shot him spontaneously and that
he was upset over Kennedy's death.
There are many conspiracy theories surrounding
the JFK assassination and the Umbrella Academy
show mines a number of those to set up various
subplots in Season 2.
For example, the Umbrella Man, who the team
mistakenly believe is their father is a real-life
person who was standing near Kennedy's motorcade
when the president was shot.
Because the real-life Umbrella Man was wearing
a large raincoat and carrying an umbrella
on a warm, sunny day in Dallas,
some believe he was there to act as a signal
for the assassination to go ahead, something
that was also referenced in The Umbrella Academy.
"..he's the signalman for the whole goddamn
thing."
The theory was called into question when Louie
Steven Witt came forward to state that he
was the Umbrella Man on the day
and that he was carrying the umbrella to protest
the Kennedy family's appeasement policy towards
Nazi Germany in the 30s.
In the show, the shadowy Majestic 12 organisation
turns out to be behind JFK's murder.
In real-life, the Majestic 12 are a purported
secret organisation whose existence is popular
among UFO conspiracy theorists,
although the FBI and others say the existence
of the secret society is a hoax.
Among the alleged real-life members of the
group is Roscoe H. Hillenkoetter who was the
first director of the CIA.
He's referenced in the show on an invitation
card to the gala at the Mexican Consulate,
which is where we see the Majestic 12 meet
for the first time.
The TV show plays up the nefarious nature
of the Majestic 12 and how they seem to be
secretly influencing events.
The sunglasses man often pops up in the background
of various scenes.
For example, he seems to be on friendly terms
with Jack Ruby when we see the club owner
briefly talking to him in the first episode
"You OK here?"
Could this be the show suggesting a connection
between the Majestic 12 and Jack Ruby's subsequent
murder of Lee Harvey Oswald?
And the same sunglasses man is watching on
during Pogo's astronaut training.
He's a bit of an enigma and the way he seems
to be constantly smoking reminds me of The
Smoking Man from The X-Files.
And the X-Files gets its own shout-out when
conspiracy theorist Elliott first meets Five
and asks if UFOs and crop circles are real,
and Five replies using the famous tagline
from the sci-fi TV series:
"Well, the truth is out there."
And given Elliott's interest in spaceships
and aliens, I can't help but wonder if his
character was named after the little boy,
Elliot,
who befriended an extra-terrestrial in E.T.
Even before it's revealed that Reginald Hargreeves
is an alien in season 2's penultimate episode,
there are little hints at his true form.
For example, Diego warns Grace about Hargreeves
"and his nasty squad of lizard people".
And costume designer Christopher Hargadon
told Nerdist that he specifically gave Hargreeves
"lizard shoes"
and more vibrant clothes than his colleagues
as he wanted to indicate that there was "something
strange about the guy".
And the face mask that Hargreeves removes
from his head is also a reference to the same
mask that reveals his alien origins in the
comics.
The season finale reveals the apparent end
of the Umbrella Academy and their replacement
with the Sparrow Academy.
And the episode's title "The End of Something"
is a clever call-back to the first season
when the Handler cryptically explained to
Five that the apocalypse wasn't the end of
everything but..
"Just the end of... something."
Now, you doubtless noticed the Handler's outfits
getting more and more flamboyant as the season
progressed and her power grew within the Commission.
But there were some more subtle details that
also mirrored her rise to power.
For example, in the third episode you can
spot a small red spider brooch on her handbag.
By the ninth episode there's a bigger spider
brooch and it's migrated onto her outfit and
by the finale it's climbed all the way up
to her hat
The spiders seem to reflect the ever-growing
web that the Handler spins in Season 2 as
her status rises.
And the red sequined shoes that the camera
focusses on when the Handler arrives during
the murder of Lila's parents
are a possible allusion to the Ruby Slippers
from the Wizard of Oz which originally belonged
to the Wicked Witch of the East.
The song "Bibbidi-Bobbidi-Boo" which plays
when the Handler returns to the Commission
is a subtle reference to Cinderella's Fairy
Godmother,
the twist here being that for Lila the Handler
ends up being a wicked mother to her who deliberately
orchestrated the murder of her parents.
Lila's ability to copy or mirror the Umbrella
crew's powers is a pretty awesome reveal in
the final episode, and when Fives asks her
how she can do it, she simply replies
"Anything you can do, I can do better"
Which is a little reference to the duet of
the same name from the musical Annie Get Your
Gun where the two singers compete to outdo
each other performing the same tasks.
There's a neat bit of foreshadowing of Harlan's
arc when in the opening episode Vanya tells
Sissy that she and Harlan have been reading
James and the Giant Peach.
In the popular novel by Roald Dahl, a young
boy ends up going on a fantastical adventure
with seven magical bugs, a possible parallel
to Harlan and the seven members of the Umbrella
Academy.
"I know you don't get it, but that is an excellent
reference."
And after Harlan becomes connected to Vanya
through the powers that she transfers to him,
he seems to have some foresight or ability
to sense the future.
In the eighth episode, you can see Harlan
drawing a picture of somebody flying above
the farmhouse and barn,
a foreshadowing of how Vanya will later float
out of the barn to attack the Handler's army
of Commission agents in the finale.
There've been plenty of comparisons between
The Umbrella Academy and other popular superhero
teams such as the X-Men and Doom Patrol,
with Vanya's powerful abilities that sometimes
threaten to rage out of control often reminding
people of Jean Grey and Dark Phoenix.
And it feels like there's a Jean Grey-esque
moment in Season 2 when Vanya levitates the
water out of the lake where Harlan drowns.
Ellen Page who plays Vanya joined the X-Men
movies as Kitty Pryde in X-Men The Last Stand,
and in that film when the Phoenix force rages
out of control in Jean Grey, she levitates
a wall of water around Alcatraz.
And suitably for a time-travel apocalypse
story, The Umbrella Academy also squeezes
in a reference to the Terminator movies when
Hazel shows up in the midst of the 1963 doomsday
and tells Five:
"If you wanna live, come with me."
I just love the incredible attention to detail
in the series and all the creative easter
eggs added for the fans.
And if you feel inspired by the show's inventiveness,
give an outlet to your own imagination on
Squarespace, a fantastic platform that you
can easily use to build your own online presence.
Whether you're looking to start your own blog
or podcast, or open an online store, there
are tons of amazing ready-made templates that
you can rapidly customise to fit your requirements.
You don't need any technical knowledge, but
24/7 support is always at hand if you have
any questions or need some help.
You can also easily connect your site with
social platforms like Twitter and Facebook,
and set up email marketing campaigns to help
you grow and connect with your visitors.
So head on over to Sqaurespace.com/Flicks
or follow the link in the video description
below where you can try the platform completely
free for 14 days.
And when your site is ready to launch, you'll
get an extra 10% discount with that link.
So, what other easter eggs or cool details
did you spot in Season 2?
Comment below and if you enjoyed this video
a thumbs-up is hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my full breakdown of who's behind
the Sparrow Academy and how the timelines
have changed for Season 3 or tap right for
something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!